adam we're going to ursula on the line
now
by the end of september this draft bill
is by its very nature a breach
of the obligation of good faith laid
down
in the withdrawal agreement moreover
if adopted as is it will be in full
contradiction to the protocol of ireland
northern ireland the deadline lapsed
yesterday
the problematic provisions have not been
removed
therefore this morning the commission
has
decided to send a letter of formal
notice
to the uk government this is the first
step
in an infringement procedure
the letter invites the uk government to
send
its observations um within a month
and besides this the commission will
continue to work hard
towards a full and timely implementation
of the withdrawal agreement we stand by
our commitments
thank you
well there we go fairly uh shortened to
the points there from uh ursula von der
line let's hear what uh adam parsons our
europe correspondent in brussels
made of that adam really confirming what
you were just saying
yeah exactly it is those good faith
articles that the uk government is now
accused of breaching as you said short
sweet
and to the point i understand that all
of the commissioners
so-called college of commissioners
representing the the eu members
supported this action which i i do think
one thing that this will play out in
brexit negotiations in
is that there is unanimity at the moment
among eu members behind michelle barnier
behind ursula fonda line
in terms of brexit talks they've been at
pains to show that and this is another
demonstration of that unanimous support
for this legal action i think before we
get too far ahead of ourselves we should
say
that there are literally hundreds of
infringement proceedings on the book at
the moment they take a long time to go
through they certainly won't be done
by the end of this year but they in
theory this infringement proceeding
would go
on beyond the end of the transition
period
at the end of december that is also part
of the withdrawal agreement so the legal
proceedings in theory could carry on
uh way into 2021 2022
and would also in theory end up at the
the ecj
of course such a hated institution among
uh many brexiteers but i think one thing
this does do is raise
uh the temperature the the friction that
has been caused in political circles
here by the internal markets bill
and by that threat to the withdrawal
agreement is very high and i suppose the
fact is that once the european union had
threatened legal action
it really had to go through with it
whether this will
affect speed up or slow down brexit
negotiations remains to be seen because
literally across the road from where
ursula von delight
was just speaking michelle barnier and
david frost
lord frost are continuing brexit talks
today but as mr barnier is fond of
saying the clock
is ticking by common consent
a deal really has to be agreed by the
end of this month by the end of october
if it is to have much hope of getting
passed by all of european governments
european parliament and indeed the
british government
by the end of this year all right adam
thanks for that
well let's get some more reaction now
from westminster speaking to our
political correspondent rob powell rob
what looked like quite a wheeze from
number 10 advisers to try and turn up
the gas on
the negotiators looks to backfired
rather
well i'm not sure ian whether the
government will be too
bothered or too concerned about what has
just been announced we're waiting for an
official line
from the government but i'm being
pointed towards one of those stats that
adam just talked about about the number
of infringement cases that the eu
currently has open 800 in total i'm told
with about 30 against each
member states so i think the reaction
you will get
uh maybe um behind the scenes if not on
the record from the uk
side and from the negotiating team um
will be to try and paint this
um as really the eu just following
through
on what they said but also as not
unusual
for the eu either i think
there was always a degree in terms of
this internal market bill
of this playing into the trade
negotiations boris johnson said even in
a newspaper article
that actually not voting for the
internal market bill would make it
harder
to get a good trade deal so i think we
can't remove what was going on with that
from the context
of trying to get that future
relationship and i i
think this action from the eu this
infringement proceedings from the eu
will probably be viewed by those in
westminster as
part of the sort of rough and tumble tit
for tat
of the trade negotiations and don't
forget as adam was saying these
proceedings can take
a very long time to come to fruition to
get a definite
result and it may well be that we have
reached a point where
a deal is done or a deal is not done
before we actually find out
any eventual result of these proceedings
so at the moment
i think it will probably be shrugged off
here in westminster albeit
expect to see the opposition expect to
see labour the lib dems the smpcs on
this
as evidence of the uk government acting
beyond
international law and acting as they see
it in an irresponsible way